the days of Swiss watchmaker sitting out
of the SmartWatch arms race are firmly
behind us Breitling is the latest to
enter the fray with the excess base v55
chronograph the b55 has a beefy 46
millimeter case made from black titanium
and a bright blue rubber strap it looks
like a real aviation tool not a gadget
and borrowed from Breitling's earlier
aerospace line of watches our two little
screens on the dial that let you control
all the extra functions with the crown
and the pushers the big news though is
the app which connects the b55 to your
iPhone
this lets you use your phone to set the
watch control the timers or swap time
zones with ease conversely the watch can
now push its timing data back to the
phone letting you keep track of event
times over the long run and like with
most smartwatches the watch can buzz
when you get a text or have an
appointment coming up the excess base
b55 is available now and is priced at
$8,900 a clear signal that this is meant
to compete with high-end mechanical
watches not whatever the latest devices
from Apple or Motorola it's unclear what
the future of Swiss smartwatches looks
like but for now Breitling's b55 is one
of the more compelling concepts out
there